you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is a game
between Harry Nelson Pillsbury who's
playing the white side versus a manual
asker who at the time was world champion
played in 1904 and it's from the
Cambridge Springs Tournament so let's
see these two very dynamic players in
action it is just a 30 move encounter so
the game kicks off with Pillsbury's d4
last curry playing d5 and after c4 and
e6 we have a Queens gambit declined and
to be a bit more exact
after this c5 advance we have a tirage
setup often denoted by tension between
both C and D pawns and what's may be
most common is to be first capturing on
d5 and only then playing Bishop g5 but
it is on this fifth move the immediate
pinning of the knight C takes D Queen
takes Knight c6 with tempo with an
attack on the Queen but she doesn't have
to react just yet instead white first
inserts Bishop takes Knight and only
after it's recapture Queen to h4 where
we have a situation where White has
given up the bishop pair but imposed
some structural defect on the black side
namely those doubled F pawns there are a
couple options that black has here
capturing with the Queen well we're
entering now a more simplified position
of course namely the endgame where I
believe it is white who stands better
due to better pawn structure I believe
having the better pawn structure will
outweigh black having the bishop pair
and well this Knight will have a
wonderful home on d4 and be well
supported with e3 additionally if after
Bishop takes Knight if we have Knight
takes Queen well this is no good because
while black is up a material for the
moment this Knight is now stuck and soon
enough the rook will be picking it up
and as is often the case the two minor
pieces will be outweighing the rook so
instead the battle is the battle that
goes on here is the two bishops black
trying to show
to bishops is an asset and why trying to
show that this structure is a liability
so a d take C rook d1 making use of this
only open file hitting the Queen and she
can't go too far just to watch over f6
so we have this half developing move
Bishop d7 off the back rank but beyond
that not doing a whole lot instead
having to be worked into a pin for the
moment
III more development nightly v tension
between the Knights the tension is
resolved the Knights are exchanged and
now we have tension between the Queen's
they are not exchanged why not black has
the more vulnerable King let's keep the
most powerful piece on the board Queen
b6 hit this hits at the vulnerable point
B to something that's ignored instead
white ops to complete development with
Bishop e2 Lasker picks up this pawn and
now white completes development with
these rooks now being in direct contact
with one another
rook c8 at first glance looks as if it's
going to be picking up the knight but
black has their own worries there's a
mate threat on d7 rook c7 to defend and
now Knight to e4 eyes both a d6 and f6
Bishop e7 is there this is one of those
convenient moves the bishop is
essentially dominating the night when
there is a couple squares separation
between the two that Bishop will be
often doing just that and we'll see a
little bit later on this same thing
going on only with the light square
Bishop Knight d6 with the Czech King to
FA Knight C for gaining a temple on the
Queen and also putting pressure on e5 so
the Queen reacts by playing to b5
putting the knight in in a pin in some
sense and also defending e5 black is
more than welcome to having the Queen's
off at this point
f4 this is the last well what does white
have to do at this point Knight Queen
Bishop and rook are all working it's
only this rook that is not doing
something so you don't necessarily have
to move the rook but rather move the
pawn that's in front of it especially if
you could be creating tension between an
opposing pawn
as is the case right here this next move
is the main blunder of the game really
this capture on f4 is now allowing white
to finish out this game with the next 10
moves or so where each move packs a
really big punch and black is constantly
having to react to all of these
different threats what's maybe a better
move after f4 is to play e4 and try and
shut down this F file try and keep it
closed and know full well that if this
pawn is picked off maybe now the tables
will turn how exactly well the bishop
confers hit the Queen and after she
reacts soon enough we're going to be
having rook to g8 and all of a sudden
it's white who's maybe having to make
some defensive moves we do not have that
however instead it is e takes F and not
what one might think the immediate
recapture on f4 what would you do in
this position as white if you'd like to
pause the video and see if you can find
what white played next okay white played
the move Queen the efforts to me Queen
to d4 which is this f4 square and this
is a very important general principle to
maybe be following it's maybe a good
idea to not immediately recapture upon
that you know is not going to be going
too far away something which is static
and lacking in mobility right now let's
hit twice if you hit it a third time
there's probably not a way your opponent
is going to be able to defend it so it's
maybe better to have a queen being the
one who recaptures on that f4 square and
sure enough we'll see what kind of great
effect that that can have for example
after this Queen d4 move if the rook is
reacting or the King is reacting to
defend the rook let's just run with this
one going to a half-open file now when
the Queen recaptures this dual threat of
hitting the rook and looking at mate
Black is dead
we're best-case scenario for black
they're down a rook
so piling up on this pond rather than
immediately recapturing it is turning
out to be very effective in this case f6
is the best reply shutting down this
diagonal and now after the Queen
recaptures on f4 there is not the main
threat but rather just this one threat
hitting the rook Queen to c5 to defend
places this pawn and a pin as well and
now we have Knight to e5 exploiting this
this pond which is pinned and we're
hitting at d7 and once again we're
seeing that the bishop is keeping a
close eye on this Knight two squares of
separation between the two Knight g4
piling up on the weak link at this point
f6 hit three times defended only once f5
is the reaction in now we have first
Queen to h6 with check King to f7 and
now what exactly Bishop c4 a very very
sharp move of course if the bishop is
taken we land this not that one we land
this deadly fork queen is dead and one
other thing to note is that well this
pawn is hit twice and another way to
view it is that this pawn is now pinned
a very important detail because now
after rook to c6 can you spot the move
what move would you play in this
position if you'd like to pause the
video see if you can find the best move
for white best move for white in this
position is rook takes f5 and now what
do you do the pawn can't be capturing
it's in a pin the Queen is the one who
recaptures and now we have a skewer the
queen is dead Queen takes rook King
takes and now once again this bishop
cannot be taken the knight will once
again be landing there with the fork
picking up the rook
so what we have instead is Bishop to d7
I believe the king is maybe looking to
run in this direction but white rules
that one out by playing to this diagonal
King to g8 and now after Knight to e5
this Queen and Knight very deadly
combination of attacking pieces there's
absolutely nothing to do and black
ends up resigning there is a mate threat
on f7 and maybe the best thing to try
and do is run away but you're not going
to be running away too far this will be
leading to a forest mate after this
Knight to f6 move the Queen is looking
at both the g3 or even g4 for mate
so Bishop takes Knight Queen recaptures
with mate on e2 the Queen and Bishop are
scissoring the King and that would be
checkmate but as it stood in this game
after this Knight to e5 move right here
on this 30th move Knight to e5 black
ends up resigning so that's all for this
video as always I hope you got something
out of it take care bye